nein sie denn trotzdem natürlich auf
jeden fall egal ich will schlagschuss
kurz vorher will aber alleine ich mit
meiner familie und das angebot ist
verboten
vielleicht ja wenn verboten ist da marco
knaller berliner straße von heute weil
das schon seit wochen mehr oder weniger
extra aktionen geben soll wo
begleitdamen
die gerade lebt es macht spaß und
freunde
ja aber wenn es verboten mit silvester
vielleicht macht trotz mit diesem
eigentlich nicht weitergekommen heute zu
tun haben unfallgefahr
aber nicht zu erwarten werden
wahrscheinlich auch vor
wenn man sich privat lässt kann man es
machen so wie jetzt hier auf große
plätze bramberger tor das er jetzt da
erst mal sagen aber klar wir verbieten
durch diese maßnahmen alle drum und dran
kann man es vielleicht ein bisschen
nachvollziehen
ja aber ansonsten war so privat
hausgebrauch ist der einfache bürger
angeht und einkaufen geht und sagt anne
clark machen bisschen was für meine
kinder oder so
die kinder müssen nicht darunter sein
ich bin selber familienvater und da muss
sich verpflichten die kinder nicht
runter zu leiten soweit also die stimmen
aus berlin aus der hauptstadt wie hat
aber doch mal genauer nachgefragt und
wollten wissen haben eine insa umfrage
in auftrag gegeben wollten wissen sind
sie für ein verkaufsverbot während
corona also während der pandemie aktuell
47 prozent sind dafür dagegen sind 37 ja
und die mehrheit würde also einem
verkaufsverbot zustimmen während der
jetzigen situation wir wollten einmal
genauer wissen wer ist denn für dieses
verbot und da sehen wir paare ohne
kinder 51 prozent sind für ein verbot
während der kubakrise und 39 familie mit
kindern sind auch dafür aber das
natürlich deutlich weniger
das hat mich jetzt zum beispiel
überrascht ich dachte dass wir eher
andersrum dieses verhältnis das mehr
familien für ein verbot sind dann wollen
wir doch mal generell auf das verbot
schauen weil das natürlich nicht neu ist
es gibt immer wieder diskussionen wenn
silvester näher rückt sind
feuerwerkskörper
toll oder eben nicht deswegen haben wir
auch gefragt sind sie für ein
dauerhaftes verbot dafür sind 69 prozent
dagegen sind 27 zu den zahlen muss man
aber auch sagen dass wir nur die stimmen
gewertet haben die auch eine klare
angabe gegeben haben also enthaltungen
sind hier nicht dabei wir haben uns auch
noch mal die geschlechter aufteilung
etwas genauer angeschaut und zwar nach
männern und frauen 72 prozent der frauen
sind also für ein dauerhaftes verbot
könnten also komplett auf das ballern
und raketen zünden verzichten
da würde ich mich glatt anschließend
unterschreiben bei männern ist es etwas
weniger aber dennoch immerhin finde ich
persönlich eine relativ hohe zahl 65
prozent der männer könnten also auch
darauf verzichten ja zu silvester zu
knallen böller zu schießen und raketen
in die luft
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren